hey this is really weird Donald Trump
interrupted a phone call with the new
Irish Prime Minister Lee over add car to
call over an Irish reporter who had a
strong resemblance to his own daughter
Ivanka Trump to his desk in the Oval
Office to comment on her physical
appearance the reporter was Katrina
Perry the Washington correspondent for
an Irish public broadcaster and we've
got a clip of this and it is bizarre
this seems sort of like what you would
see in a Saturday Night Live skit
parodying Donald Trump but this is this
is real stuff folks well we have a lot
of your Irish press watching this now
and where are you from go ahead we have
all this beautiful
[Music]
Katrina Perrin here's a nice smiling
face so I'm a cutie - well I feel
genuinely bad for Katrina Perry and the
look on her face as she was walking away
from the the desk in the Oval Office is
the look of an employee in an office who
just had her boss come over to talk to
her about her latest TPS reports while
standing just a little bit too close and
sort of awkwardly resting his hand on
her lower back and you know what
occurred to me Trump was on the phone
with liova rad car the new Irish prime
minister who is gay
imagine if Donald Trump thought crap I'm
on the phone with a gay guy I'd better
do something to make sure everybody
knows I'm not gay why don't I call over
a female reporter and compliment her
looks maybe it is it at all possible
this is what matters like probably I
don't know about that it seems like I
don't know if Trump definitively crossed
any lines here but it also seems as
though he's had so much practice in
trying to thread that needle yeah and it
makes you think that with all this grab
them by the [ __ ] talk and the many
sexual harassment and assault
allegations there's more of a chance
that they're true after we witness this
well if Obama did this right-wingers
would be calling for his head right
people flipped when Obama was merely
photographed with his feet on the desk
in the Oval Office and Trump is calling
someone over
and talking about their their good looks
while on the phone with the leader of
another nation BuzzFeed news tried to
reach out to Katrina Perry for more
information but a communications manager
for RTE replied that she is quote not
doing any further interviews at the
moment it's all just sort of creepy
right in an employment situation it
would definitely be sexual harassment
and you're right that Donald Trump has
this long history of sort of threading
the needle between what's appropriate
and what's not appropriate and what's
flat-out sexual assault it's also just
really weird how the reporter resembles
Trump's own daughter Ivanka who by the
way Trump has talked about how amazing
his own daughter's body is and how if he
wasn't related to her he would he would
love to be dating someone with her body
it's just all very creepy but don't
worry this is a blip Republicans don't
care about sexual harassment unless it's
a Democrat who does it so I wouldn't
worry Pat yeah very strange and you can
tell that this woman was really
perturbed by this oh yeah by the look on
her face by how quickly she wanted to
get out of that area right after it has
started like trying to take steps back
almost immediately when it started
getting weird with Trump and then again
the look on her face when she turns
around it's just it's crushing